>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Good morning.
I'm Stephanie Marcus from
the Science, Technology,
and Business Division
here at the Library.
Back in the fall of 2015 when we
were looking at topics that a woman
from NASA who we work with in
outreach gave us we saw a long list
of things and there were
so many great topics
that we did choose eight
instead of the normal six.
But among them was
gravitational waves,
and we were going, "What's that?"
Nobody seemed to know.
And at that time none had been
detected although they had been
trying to detect them for
at least 15 years or --
>> Forty years?
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Well, a hundred years.
Einstein was the one who
theorized that these things existed
and sometimes he was poo-pooed
and sometimes he was believed.
And, finally, in February of this
year they had the first detection
in two of the sites in
Washington state and in Louisiana.
And it was just a chirp from the
collision of two black holes.
So this was really phenomenal
and everybody was so excited
and we were excited that that
was a topic we had chosen,
and we were looking so savvy.
We always like to be with it.
And people were calling
us and saying,
"You going to have a lecture
on gravitational waves?"
And we said, "Yes, we are."
It was originally planned
for November
but there was a new child
coming into the world
in Dr. Thorpe's family
on that very day, maybe.
And so we moved it up to August.
And we're glad because
we really wanted to get
into this topic while it was hot
and it will be hot for a long time.
>> Ira Thorpe: [Inaudible]
the next century.
>> Stephanie Marcus: So a little bit
about Dr. Thorpe before we start.
He's an astrophysicist
in the Gravitational Astrophysics
Laboratory at NASA Goddard.
He earned degrees in Mechanical
Engineering and Physics at Bucknell
and an MS in Physics from the
University of Maryland College Park.
So he's been local.
And after that he got his
PhD -- where is the PhD --
Florida, the University of Florida.
So he's also a graduate gator.
>> Ira Thorpe: Mm-hmm.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
And he did a post-doc
at NASA before he began his
employment there in 2009.
He's received both individual
and team awards at Goddard
for his work on gravitational waves.
So please help me in welcoming Dr.
Thorpe to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Ira Thorpe: Well, thank
you very much Stephanie
for the warm introduction.
Thanks for everyone for coming, and
thank you very much for the Library
for inviting me to come out
and have this opportunity
to talk to everybody.
And I'm ecstatic we've
got a packed house.
So let's just get right to it.
So I figured that since I
was coming to the Library
of Congress I should do something
related with documents, right?
Now I'm not a historian.
I'm a scientist.
There are a lot of science
historians that do this stuff
for a living so I'm going
to, you know, basically --
yeah, take this with
a grain of salt.
But these are 10 papers that
I picked that I think are sort
of relevant for telling the
story of gravitational waves.
And so they go all the way from,
not surprisingly, Einstein in 1915,
a hundred years ago, to two
papers from this year in 2016.
You notice these guys both
start with the letter A,
and that's because this is like
a thousand people and this is,
you know, about hundred people.
So that shows you also a difference
in how science has been done
in the last hundred years, the
era of large collaborations.
So starting right away
with Einstein,
so this is a paper from 1915.
I don't speak German, but
this basically says, you know,
on the theory of relativity
or general relativity
and general relativity.
So people associate Einstein
with this idea of relativity.
And some people don't realize
that there's actually two
theories of relativity.
And the special relativity one
is the one that happened first.
And it's the one that told us about
this idea that there's nothing
that can go faster than
the speed of light.
And that's one of the
sort of postulates
of the theory of special relativity.
And that was a very successful,
successful theory and in made,
you know, Einstein famous in
sort of scientific circles.
But he wasn't really famous in the
general public circles at that time.
But one of the things that
was pretty quickly realized is
that Newton's theory or gravity
which, again, was very successful
because we could use it to
predict the motion of the planets,
didn't match with special
relatively.
And, in particular, if you
had an object, you know,
some piece of mass, and you
moved it, the information
that that had moved, you know,
in terms of the gravitational
information,
in Newton's theory
propagated instantly.
So, a way to think about it is
that if you were to take the sun
and just, you know,
suddenly make it disappear,
the Earth would instantaneously
know that it was being,
getting that gravitational field.
And that's the way that it's --
that sort of information
would be propagating faster
than the speed of light.
And Einstein said, gosh,
that just can't work.
That doesn't, you know, that doesn't
jive with special relativity.
And this is sort of showing you that
-- the genius that it's Einstein.
You know, he doesn't say, well,
maybe my theory's wrong
and Newton's right.
He goes, well, maybe our whole
idea of gravity is wrong, right?
And it takes him years and years and
years to finally figure out and come
up with this theory of general
relativity which I'll try
to explain a little bit
in the following way.
So we know general
relativity's about gravity.
And if you usually ask
people, you say, well,
how do we know about gravity?
And they say, well, that's easy.
I just drop something and
there you go, gravity, right?
However, you know, you can
imagine if you had a skydiver,
and I'm being -- this
is a physicist skydiver,
so it's perfectly frictionless
which is not good for it's --
not good for skydiving but
good for this illustration.
If a skydiver releases
the ball, nothing happens.
It just sits there, right?
Because they're both
accelerating at the same rate.
And so, you know, I think
everyone would agree
that somehow gravity's involved
in that problem, but, you know,
somehow it doesn't seem to
be apparent to the skydiver
when he's measuring this, right?
And so to make a long story short,
one of the things that turns
out to really understand the
difference between just the effects
of acceleration, that is,
doing your measurement
in an accelerating
laboratory versus gravitation,
you need to make a
measurement that's not local.
That is, you need to
compare measurements
that happen at different places.
And this is an illustration of that.
So if you have two balls that are
way up high and you drop them,
you notice that they actually don't
drop in exactly parallel lines.
They actually start to get
closer to one another and that's
because they're each
travelling towards the center
of the Earth, not directly down.
So down is a different
direction when you're over here
and when you're over here, right?
And it's only -- so an accelerating
frame wouldn't give you that effect.
But gravitation does
give you that effect.
And that's a way to sort
of unequivocally determine the
difference between the fact
that you're just doing a measurement
in an accelerating laboratory
or you're doing a measurement
where there's gravitation.
So this is a really
fundamental idea for any kind
of gravitational measurement.
You need to make a measurement
over a long distance.
And when you get to
gravitational weight detectors,
which we'll eventually
get to in this talk,
you'll see that having a separated
distance is really important, okay?
And the mathematical name for this
thing is called geodesic deviation.
And it's this idea that
trajectories that are
in freefall are not parallel.
That is, they can converge
or diverge.
So you also hear this
idea of curved spacetime.
So where does this come from?
Well, this comes from this idea
that geometry and the geometry
of curvature is a nice
way to describe.
It's a perfect example of places
where you have straight
lines that converge.
So you imagine if you have a
person over here on the Equator
and a person over here
on the Equator,
and they both say they're
going to go north, right,
which on a map projection will
look like it was a straight line,
they actually come
together, and, in fact,
they meet at the North Pole, right?
So that's an example of lines that
are straight, that is, you know,
straight lines on the surface of
a sphere that converge, right.
And the reason they converge
is because the surface
that they're on is curved, right?
So people can kind of
picture that in their head.
There's a lot of math behind it.
But that's the basic idea, right,
is that, that this geometry,
this idea of curvature, can
be used to describe how things
that are straight lines, just
like those freely-falling balls
that we had in the last scene,
can converge or diverge.
And it has to do with
the underlying curvature
of the system that they're on.
So Einstein basically extends
that whole idea to space and time.
And so it's really difficult to
visualize because it's curvature
in four dimensions and so,
you know, it's almost --
it's effectively impossible
to visualize other than --
let's saying we imagine we sort of
suppress one of the other dimensions
and measure that curvature in
that some sort of extra dimension.
So here you have this idea
that spacetime is this
sort of rubber sheet.
You put something massive
like the Earth on it.
The Earth deforms that rubber sheet.
And then the other thing
that's interesting about it is
that if you have, you know,
any kind of object, you know,
a ball or even a particle of light,
it's going to follow one
of these straight lines.
But these straight lines now have
curvature to them that are produced
by that mass, you know, produced
by the mass of the Earth.
And so the way we like to say
how general relativity works is
that matter tells spacetime
how to curve,
so depending upon the distribution
of matter in the universe,
you get a distribution of curvature.
And curvature, that is, spacetime,
tells matter how move, right?
So if things are in freefall orbits,
their freefall orbits are going
to be affected by the
background curvature of spacetime.
And in equation form this
is Einstein's equation.
So somebody asked me if I was going
to show Einstein's
equations, there you go.
It doesn't look so hard, right?
So this is an object called
the Einstein curvature tensor.
So this is a mathematical
description of, you know, spacetime.
You can write down a
curvature tensor for a ball.
You can write it down
for all kinds of things.
And then this is just
some constants.
And then this other bit here is
called the stress energy tensor.
It's basically just a way
to describe how matter is
distributed in the universe.
So that's really it.
That's Einstein equations.
Now the hard part is
that this is a set
of coupled nonlinear
differential equations
and there are very few
solutions to these equations
in terms of closed from solution.
So you kind of have this
very beautiful theory,
but there's very few
beautiful solutions, you know,
if that's one way to think about it.
So, you know, this
would just be some sort
of esoteric interesting thing
for mathematicians if it wasn't
for the fact that it actually works.
And so Einstein himself in 1916,
so a year after their
first publication,
sort of suggested three tests.
These are known as the
three classical tests
of general relativity.
And the first one Einstein basically
did himself in that same paper.
And this was because the
planet Mercury had been known
to have an orbit that wasn't closed.
And so, you know, all of our planets
are on a slightly elliptical orbit.
And what you could
watch is that axis
of the ellipse actually processes
around the sun at a very,
very slow rate -- 40
seconds of arc per century.
So a second of arc.
So you have 360 degrees in a circle.
You have 60 minutes in each degree,
and 60 seconds in each
minute, right?
So it's a 36-hundredth of a degree.
And then 40 of those per century.
Now that's an incredibly
tiny amount but astronomers
in the 19th century were already
able to notice this, right?
So maybe they measured
it as 38 instead of 40,
but they were already
able to measure those.
And Einstein found that the GR
immediately just predicted this,
and explained why, if you
do the body problem in GR,
that you actually get
this procession.
And it shows it most in Mercury
because Mercury gets closest
to the sun, and so the GR effects
are biggest when you get nearby.
The other one -- and again, this is,
this made him like
pretty famous, right?
But the one that really kicked him
off was this idea of this deflection
of light by massive bodies.
And so in 1916 he predicts this.
It turns out that there's a
major solar eclipse in 1919.
We have another one
coming up next year.
This shows you sort of how, kind
of how rare these things are.
And this guy, Arthur
Eddington, observed this.
Here's a Washington
Times , you know,
are the stars really
where we see them?
And basically they could
see this deflection
of the starlight exactly
as Einstein predicted.
Actually, it was interesting.
It took a couple of years but he
actually had to factor two mistake
in his prediction which he was able
to correct between his prediction
and the actual opportunity
to observe the eclipse.
And this is what really
makes Einstein famous, right?
The third test that he proposed
is this thing called gravitational
redshift which is the idea
that if you send some light
out of a gravitational field it will
change its color due to the fact
that it has to lose energy when it's
leaving the gravitational field.
It took, whoops, it took
until 1959 before Pound
and Rebka were actually able
to make that measurement.
So this is starting to get
you an idea of how long --
how far ahead the theory was
of the technology, right.
And that's the theme
for the rest of this.
So I mentioned that in Einstein's
equations there's very few closed
form solutions.
But there's one solution which
Einstein himself recognized
which is a wave solution.
So this is what we call
gravitational waves.
And so here's, again,
another paper from Einstein,
again a single-author paper, and
he finds out that these waves --
so, basically, mathematically,
the equations will
admit a wave solution.
That solves the equations, right?
And so he says, well, gosh,
what's the speed of these waves?
And when he works it out he
goes that's the speed of light.
He goes, well, that's
kind of interesting.
Maybe that's the way that
gravity can be compatible
with special relativity, right?
It's a way that gravitational
information can be propagated
across the universe is
in gravitational waves.
And, you know, there was a lot
of debate here because this sort
of shows you how difficult
that the math is.
Einstein and others, and actually
Einstein himself went back
and forth about, you
know, is this real,
is this a mathematical
artifact, is it real?
And Eddington, the very
same guy that had made
that eclipse measurement,
sort of quipped
that gravitational waves
propagate at the speed of thought.
So, basically, the idea that
they're not real, right?
There just this sort of
figment of the imagination.
And this debate, you know, again,
is confined to this really sort
of small circle of theoretical
physicists that are working
on relativity, a very new science.
So what would they look like?
Well, they would be
transverse to their propagation.
So, basically, the waves stretch
and squeeze space and time.
And they stretch and squeeze them
in a direction that's orthogonal
to the way the wave is propagating.
So imagine a wave is going
into our screen here,
and you see that they
stretch and they squeeze.
And they're actually area preserving
which is kind of interesting.
So they stretch on one axis
at the same time they're
squeezing on the other one.
And then they do the opposite.
They travel at the speed
of light as I mentioned.
And they have two polarizations.
We call this one plus because it
has axes that are sort of plus.
And then this one is at 45 degrees.
We call this a cross polarization.
Yeah. So this is what
Einstein's theory sort of said.
But, again, we didn't really know.
Is this something real?
So a little bit later, all back
in -- up in 1959, there was,
after a lot of discussion, included
famous physicist Richard Feynman,
these guys Bondi, Pirani, and
Robinson published this paper
that really showed that
you could extract energy
from these gravitational waves and,
therefore, they must be real, right.
And this was basically the
argument that they had.
So their argument was,
imagine you had a rod and on
that rod you had some beads.
And those beads were
a little sticky.
You know, they basically
were able to slide on the rod
but they rubbed a little bit.
And they showed that if you
have a gravitational wave come
by it makes these beads
go back and forth.
Those beads rub on the rod.
It heats up the rod.
And the rod's warmed up, right?
And so the fact that energy has
shown up in that rod shows you
that that energy came from
these gravitational waves.
It's one of these beautiful thought
experiments that sort of shows.
And I was trying to actually
build something like that.
Took, you know, another
40 years, right?
But, basically, that's
the fundamental idea
that says, you know what?
It might actually be possible
to detect these things, okay?
So, so that was a very important,
important breakthrough as well.
And at the same time, people
were starting to trying
to understand well, okay, where
in nature might we actually find
gravitational waves?
So, again, there was this idea that,
well, general relativity was sort
of interesting for these
very small effects of things
like [inaudible] shift of Mercury
and deflecting light by the sun.
But it wasn't really
important for astrophysics.
Well, these guys, Peters and
Matthews, in '63, were able to sort
of do an approximate solution
of Einstein's equations.
And I'll talk about
it a little bit more.
But what they basically
showed is for a binary system,
and binary star systems
of various kinds are one
of the most common
types of star systems
that we have in the universe.
Most stars are in binaries.
And they showed that
they actually lose energy
because they'll radiate
gravitational waves
and that will affect
the orbit of the binary.
And they made a quantitative
prediction for how fast
that energy would change
and basically how strong the
gravitational waves would be.
So here's the basic idea.
So I've got two stars or two
black holes or two neutron stars
or a planet and a star, you
know, whatever you like.
They're orbiting around one another.
And if you work out
Einstein's equations, as Peters
and Matthews did, you find out
that they, that those stars
as they orbit will
release energy and momentum
in the form of gravitational waves.
Now, that energy has to come from
somewhere, and where it comes
from is in the orbit
of the two objects.
So, basically, they fall
closer to one another.
So if you look at Newtonian
mechanics, when they fall closer
to one another they
have to speed up, right?
So they speed up and now
they're closer to one another.
They're moving faster.
And so the amount of energy
they release is even greater.
And so you can very quickly see
that this is a runaway process.
You basically, you know,
lose a little bit of energy.
You get closer.
You lose more energy.
And it gets up, up,
up, up, up, up, up.
Until eventually these things
crash into one another.
Now, Peters and Matthews could
sort of predict by extrapolating
where they would crash
into one another.
But the math that they used
to do this extrapolation didn't work
once you got the things really close
to one another, right?
Basically, all these approximations
that they had to use break
down when they try to get the
stars almost touching, right?
And so, at least for this
part of it, it's interesting.
For this part you're going
to need something new.
And I'll talk about
that in a little bit.
So then this is what
really kicked off the field.
And this is a gentleman
that was working
up at the University of Maryland.
A very accomplished experimental
physicist named Joseph Weber.
And he starts, basically based on
these ideas from Bondi and others,
to build gravitational
wave antennas.
And he calls them these
bar detectors.
And lo and behold, he
actually claims to see a event.
And this just sets off the
whole physics community.
So here's basically how
Weber's system he used.
So he wasn't looking so much
for a binary star system.
But he was looking for pulsars
which had been recently discovered.
So pulsar's a rapidly
spinning neutron star.
And the idea is that the
pulsar has a little bump on it.
If it's anything other than a
perfect sphere, it's also going
to radiate gravitational
waves because, basically,
that bump is going to go whipping
around the top of the pulsar,
and you're going to get
gravitational waves coming out.
So that's the idea here.
And his detector's very simple.
You basically take
a bar of material,
and you want to have a
material that's got a high
mechanical quality.
So something like a
metal or a crystal.
You want it to be big so that
it can couple to these waves.
And you want it to sort of
be isolated, so suspended,
so that it's sort of
free to ring like a bell.
And if these waves come by and
they happen to have the frequency
that matches the natural
resonance frequencies
of the bar, the bar's going to ring.
And then you just have to
measure the bar ringing.
Now Weber was a very smart
experimental physicist and he knew
that there could be other things
that might cause the bar to ring.
And so he said, aha.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to build two bars
and I'm going to spread them apart.
And I'm going to put one at the
University of Maryland and I'm going
to put one at Argonne
Lab in Chicago.
And if they're spread that far apart
it's unlikely that there's any kind
of effect that can make both of
them go blip at the same time.
And when he sees both of them
go blip at the same time,
this is from his paper, he
says, gravitational wave, right?
So this got people going, you
know, really excited in the field.
So it generates this
tremendous interest.
So the astrophysicists all
sort of jump out and say, wait.
You know, how big could a mountain
be on a pulsar and how many
of them should there be out
there, and that kind of thing.
And the experimenters say, well,
I'm going to build a bar, too.
And there's like a dozen
of these major efforts
that are built all over the world.
And nobody finds anything.
So, first of all, the
astronomers say, you know,
the rates are just not really
compatible with what you're seeing.
You shouldn't have seen --
because he claims two or
three possible detections.
And they say, you know, you
just shouldn't see that many.
And the other people
building the detectors,
even though they're
actually even starting
to make little improvements,
they don't see anything.
And so eventually people
sort of start to decide
that Weber must be wrong
despite the fact that, yeah,
to his death he believed that he had
detected the gravitational waves.
So it's kind of a mixed legacy here.
So on the one hand, if
it weren't for Weber,
we never would have
gotten all of the interest
from the astrophysicists and the
experimental physics community.
And on the other hand, we sort
of got the stigma of, boy,
we're going to need to have an
absolute gold standard event before
we ever claim a real detection.
And so the communities sort
of really felt the
impact of this gentleman.
So shortly after this, a gentleman
by the name of Ray Weiss comes
up with a different kind of
detector based on lasers.
He's working at MIT.
Actually, interestingly
enough, it came out later
that two Soviet scientists had come
up with a very similar
idea a little bit earlier.
And actually this happened -- anyone
that's worked in physics has found
that during the Cold War
this happened all the time.
And now there's actually
a lot of, you know,
former Soviet Bloc physicists that
are working in U.S. institutions.
And whenever you talk to them,
they say, "You know that so
and so knew this before
the" -- yeah, right.
There's always the Russian guy
that knew it before we did.
But in any case.
So Weiss makes some
contributions here.
He built a prototype.
And really what's important.
This 1972 paper which is
actually just a publication,
in internal MIT publication, he lays
out the basic fundamentals for one
of these gravitational
wave detectors.
And this will become the detector
that eventually makes
the detection in 2015.
So here's the basic idea.
And this is more modern than
his concept at the time.
So you have a laser.
This idea is called an
interferometer, and it dates back
to this guy named Michaelson
who was working
in the 19th century
looking at ether drift.
And so I have this laser and I have
this thing called a beam splitter
which basically divides
a light into two paths.
And one light goes down this path;
one light goes down this path.
The purpose of these
mirrors, you basically --
the light bounces back and forth
between these several times
or several hundred times.
It basically effectively makes
the arm lights much bigger.
And in any event, when
they come back,
if the arms are exactly
the same length,
then the light comes
right back to the laser.
If they're off a little bit,
then some of the light comes
out to the photo-receiver.
And you can see from --
if you remember that cartoon of
how the gravitational wave worked
where it stretched in one direction
and compressed in the other
and goes back and forth -- that
this sort of L-shaped detector
where you measure the difference
between this arm and this arm,
is sort of perfect kind of antenna
for measuring gravitational wave
because that's exactly
what it looks for.
It looks for difference in
lengths between these two arms.
And so that's the basic idea.
So what's the problem?
So when we work with
gravitational waves we work
with this thing called
strain, all right?
So strain, if anybody's in
engineering as I was a while ago,
is the mechanical quality called
a change in length over length.
And the reason we use strain to
describe how big our waves are is
because it's space itself
that's stretching, right?
So if I take space and
if I take this cartoon --
you imagine I made
it twice as big --
well, then the physical
motion would be twice as big
because there's twice as much
space between the cartoon.
Everything sort of scales up, right?
So I want to make my detector,
you know, change the length
over length is what the strain is.
And this is a rough estimate
for how big the strain would be.
So you want to have -- so M
is the mass of the object,
R is sort of how close the
objects are to one another,
so you want to have a lot
of mass in a small space.
D is how far away the objects are,
so you want them relatively close.
And then you have this
kind of nasty factor
of G squared over C to the 4th.
So G is Newton's gravity constant.
That's a number that's like 710
to the minus 11 in standard units.
So that's a tiny number,
and it's squared.
And C is the speed of light.
That's 10 to the 8
meters per second,
you know, 10 to the 4th power.
That's a big number to the
4th power in the denominator.
So this factor is a killer.
And so even if you sort of
pick the most optimistic
after physical values for these,
you get a number that's
like 10 to the minus 21.
So that's a sextillionth, a
part in a billion trillion.
Small number.
So, another way to look at that
is that's about the diameter
of a hydrogen atom divided by
the distance to the sun, okay?
So that's sort of a reasonable
size amplitude to expect
for a gravitational wave.
And that's the point which most
people say, that was interesting.
I'm going to go back to doing
something else [laughter].
But, people like Weiss,
you know, from the '70s,
continued to push this, right?
And it eventually became this
thing called LIGO, right?
So LIGO, the LIGO Project grew
out of this and many other efforts
around -- so their
efforts around the world,
and the basically objective
is we're going to really try
to build something where
we think we've got a chance
of making a detection.
So they built -- it was funded
by the National Science
Foundation primarily.
They service some major
contributions
from international partners.
And there's two sites
housing four-kilometer-long
L-shaped detectors.
So this one is on the
Hanford Nuclear Reservation
in Washington state.
This one is in Louisiana.
Actually, this very near where all
this flooding is going on recently.
Fortunately, the detector
was designed
to handle a thousand-year-flood,
and it seems to be okay,
although many of the
employees are obviously
in great difficulty right now.
But they started it in 1990.
A lot of pre-project work
was going on in the '80s.
It took a while to build it.
There is a major civil
engineering infrastructure here.
They did their initial science runs.
Didn't find anything.
They didn't upgrade
to Advanced LIGO.
And in 2015 they turned
on Advanced LIGO.
I think most people know the
story there, but if you don't,
you'll get it in a few slides.
So, while LIGO was
sort of getting going,
there was another really
important event.
And, actually, this
could be claimed as sort
of the first detection
of gravitational waves.
Those of us that work in building
the gravitational wave instrument
call this an indirect detection.
So if you remember
Peters and Matthews,
this paper from the early '60s,
had this idea that as you had
two stars orbiting one another,
they would make gravitational
waves and the orbit would shrink.
And what Taylor Weisberg actually
did is they had a pulsar system,
and it was -- it actually turned
out to be a binary pulsar system,
I'll explain what that means in
a moment, that Taylor and one
of his graduate students
had discovered earlier.
And they noticed that this thing
was actually shrinking, right?
And it basically was shrinking
at the rate that was predicted
by general relativity, and
due to gravitational waves.
So that was this really
important paper
and what we'll show a
little bit more of it here.
So a pulsar is one of
these neutron stars,
the same kind of this
Weber was looking for.
But in this case, a pulsar has a
little radio beam that's pointed
in a direction that's not the same
as the axis of the star spinning it.
And we actually don't
really know why that --
the details of why that happens,
but these are very common
astrophysical objects.
So if you're a radio astronomer,
you just see this blip going by.
So if you just look at a patch
of the sky, you see blip, blip,
blip, blip, blip, blip, right?
And actually when people
first discovered these,
they thought they were
seeing alien civilizations
because it was such a regular tick.
They said, what could
that possibly be?
Well, it turns out it's a
sort of collapse core of star
with this radio beam coming out of
it, and it's spinning quite fast.
And it's got so much
rotational inertia, so much mass,
that there's really nothing that
can affect its spin very much.
And so it's a very good clock.
Now binary pulsars -- imagine
this thing is pulsing but happens
to be orbiting another neutron star
that's, let's say, not pulsing.
And all you can measure
are these pulses.
But just by timing these pulses,
and if you look over enough time,
and you're clever enough,
you can actually figure
out all the parameters of the orbit.
So you can figure out
the masses of the stars.
You can figure out the separations.
You know where they are,
et cetera, et cetera.
Then you can just plug into
Peter and Matthew's formula
and you can say, you know, how
should the orbit evolve over time?
And the answer is that line.
And the dots are the measurements.
Now if you're in -- if
you ever teach in --
I think someone we had was a
high school teacher, right?
If someone does lab and they gave
you this, you'd say, you cheated.
You moved your measurements, right?
But they didn't.
And for this they get
the Nobel Prize.
The interesting this is that
Weisberg, the guy that did a lot
of the calculations on the paper,
doesn't get the Nobel Prize.
But Holz, the guy that
discovered the pulsar, does.
So it's just sort of the vagaries
of the Nobel Prize system.
But, anyways, this is sort of,
you know, really is the last nail
in the coffin of the gravitational
wave question, are they real?
Because here we're seeing the
effect of gravitational waves
on a binary star system
in nature, right, so.
But, again, we're not really
measuring the waves themselves.
We're seeing that the waves are
sucking energy out of the system.
Okay. So now I'm going to jump
up into something a
little bit more modern.
And so that is a paper, actually,
by one of my colleagues, John Baker
and Joan Centrella, and
several others at Goddard.
There were other groups
around the world.
And what they were trying to
do is they were trying to --
again, going back to
Peters and Matthews.
They had this, this -- equations
worked sort of for the early part
of these stars spinning
around one another.
But these equations broke down
when you got really close.
And that's because
Einstein's equations,
there is no close form solution
for two stars orbiting one another.
It's called the two-body problem.
So in Newtonian mechanics
you can work it out.
Keppler worked it out.
And if you try to do it in
Einstein's equations, you know,
you can do it -- approximate
solutions for certain situations
like widely separated stars,
but when you get all the way
down to the stars, you know,
orbiting one another really
close, it doesn't work.
So the only way you can do this is
by a thing called numerical
relativity.
So you basically chop
up Einstein's equations
and you solve them
in a super computer.
And this is a very
technical computing challenge.
It took about 20 years for
people to be able to do this.
And this sort of an
illustration of two black holes,
their gravitational waves, their
trajectories, and if you're sitting
in the front, you might be
able to see some of these grids
which are the computational
meshes that are being used
to compute Einstein's
equations on a grid there.
So what did they see.
So this isn't exactly
from their paper,
but this is a kind of
representative thing.
This is the waveform.
And so you see it goes up and down
and up and down and up and down.
Now this part back here
is basically what Peters
and Matthews were seeing, right,
the fact that you have
these things oscillating.
You get this sort of
sinusoidal gravitational wave.
And if you look carefully you
see that both the frequency
of the wave gets close --
gets higher, which means basically
the waves get closer together,
right?
So you see them getting
scrunched together.
And you see that the height of wave,
or the amplitude of the wave goes
up until it reaches its maximum.
Now we call this a chirp because if
you were to try to make this sound,
or you play this through, it goes
from low frequency/low amplitude
to a higher frequency amplitude.
So it goes whoooooop, right?
And that's exactly what a
gravitational wave sounds like,
right?
And it was -- numerical
relativity was needed
to get this detail, right?
So this is what we needed
a super computer for.
This you could do,
you know, kind of,
kind of with that Peters
and Matthews formula.
This starts to get a little harder.
And when you get up to this part,
you need to have a super computer.
And so the other important
about these wave forms is
that they can encode
astrophysical information.
So the precise rate at which this
thing rises up tells you something
about the mass of the
system that's involved.
And there's other kinds of
information you can figure out from,
say, those two different
polarizations.
This is just plotting
one polarization.
But if you plot the other
polarization, you can figure
out the angle of the
system, and the distance,
and all kinds of interesting things.
So this really critical for
being able to do science
with the gravitational waves as
opposed to just detecting them.
So here's a picture of a chirp.
So we're in a library.
This is the library at my alma
mater, at Bucknell University.
And you're going to
see it get chirped.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't have time to do one
at the Library of Congress.
But, right?
So I did that with my laptop.
So, basically, that's -- you
see, you see -- I'll play it --
Let me see if I can play it again.
All right.
So what you see is that the --
that wave is increasing in
amplitude and in frequency.
So they get stretched more and
more and more and faster and faster
and faster, and then it
rings down after the merger.
So that's what a chirp looks like.
Now that's a maximum strain
of about 10% as opposed
to 10 to the minus 21, right?
So that's why, if you plot
it with 10 to the minus 21,
it doesn't look like much.
Okay. So now we'll get to the,
for the rest of the talk here,
the main events, which is
what happened last year.
And, actually, it was last September
that the detection was made.
And it wasn't until February
that it was announced.
So Advanced LIGO, which is
this major upgrade to LIGO.
Remember LIGO was built -- they did
this several years of science run.
They didn't detect anything.
So then they went and they
did this upgrade and, again,
it shows the NSF being,
you know, pretty reasonable
about saying we're going give you
yet more funding to do an upgrade
when we haven't detected anything.
So they do this upgrade.
And they're in just what they
call their final commissioning.
They haven't officially
started their observing run.
So everything's on and basically
configured the same way it's going
to be during their observing run.
But they're not officially
started yet.
And on September 14th
they get a big signal.
And people said, you know,
was that an injection?
Because occasionally they will
put it in injections to check
that their data pipelines
will actually catch it, right?
And people said, no,
there's no injections
on the, you know, on that day.
And eventually, you know, a bunch
of signal analyses, they figure out,
yeah, that this was real,
and this was two black holes
and two big black holes
pretty far away.
And what was astounding is this
thousand-member collaboration was
able to keep this thing
secret, mostly, for six months.
And it was eventually
announced on February 11th.
And actually the person
that was most responsible
for leaking this was not a
member of the collaboration
and he didn't really know.
But they were pretty
annoyed with him.
I won't name any names.
So, you know, this is all stuff
from February 12th, or
February 11th, right?
So, basically, the same day.
So you get, you know,
a nice combination
of old media and new media, right?
So you got front page above
the fold New York Times .
this is inside one of the
vacuum tubes inside LIGO.
So that people that do their
vacuum engineering are like, aha,
it was us that got to be on the
New York Times , not, you know,
not you silly scientists.
And here you get Obama
tweeting, you know?
So that's a kind of
measure of success here.
You get another new media.
This is Mark Zuckerberg here from
Facebook posting on Facebook saying,
you know, "This is one of
the greatest discoveries
of modern science, right?
And Einstein would be proud."
And then, finally, this
is from the New Yorker .
And the bird's saying to
the other, "Was that you
or two black holes crashing into
one another [laughter]," right?
So this really comes into
the public consciousness
which makes me doing by job easier.
You know, for a while, when
I would sit on airplanes,
and people would say what do you do?
You know, ah, I'm going to have
to explain all this what I do.
And now you just say
gravitational waves
and [finger snap] bank,
they know it, right?
So this really great.
Although I think the news cycle --
we need some more events [laughter].
So what do they really see?
So this is what came out
of the Hanford detector.
So here's the detector
in Washington.
So you see this is strain in a
unit that it doesn't really matter.
But it's basically in those
10 to the minus 21 units.
So it's bouncing back and forth.
And then you see this little wiggle.
Now I think most could
would say, really?
You know, that's, that's it?
That's a wiggle?
Well, what really makes this
convincing is if you go look
at what happened in Louisiana.
So you have to shift the
thing in time a little bit
because it actually takes the light
in a gravitational wave some time
to travel across the country.
And look, it's exactly
the same, right?
And even more interesting is
if you match it up with one
of those numerical relativity
templates, you get the red line
as a numerical relativity
and then the sort
of grey lines are the measured
wave form out of the detector.
And they match quite exactly.
And by matching them, you get to
sort of choose things like the mass
in order to get the maximum mass.
You're actually going
to measure the mass.
So this is really cool.
Thirty-six solar masses, 29
solar masses, add up to being one
at 62 solar masses, and at a
distance of 410 magaparsecs.
So, can anybody tell me
what looks wrong with this?
Any math teachers -- what's that?
>> The [inaudible].
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah, right.
So 36 plus 29 equals 65 not 62.
So, okay, there's some error bars.
Maybe that's what's going on.
That's not what's going on.
Three solar masses of energy left
the system in gravitational waves
in less than a second, right?
So that's -- so we've heard
of E equals MC squared.
If there's one formula everybody
knows, it E equals MC squared.
So take the mass of the
sun, multiply it by 3,
multiply it by the
speed of light squared.
You get the amount of
energy that left the system.
A tremendous amount of energy.
The fact that peak power is
about 3 times 10 to the 49 watts.
That's about a thousand times
brighter than a gamma ray burst
which is generally considered
the brightest astrophysical
individualized physical event.
It's about 10 times brighter
than all of the stars
in all the visible universe
combined for that second.
And yet, it was all coming
out in gravitational waves.
No light at all, right?
So people sometimes say
gravitational waves are weak.
They're not weak.
They're very strong.
They're just hard to detect.
Now that wasn't it for LIGO.
So they had their first
observing run.
So there had been this
sort of series of upgrades
to get Advanced LIGO up
to its full sensitivity.
So this is the big
one on September 14th.
There was a confirmed detection.
They had another candidate which
they didn't claim to be a detection.
But it's statistically pretty
likely to be a detection.
Something like, you know,
95% to be a detection.
And then they had another very
strong confirmed detection just
after Christmas they
called the Boxing Day Event.
It refers to the international
nature of the collaboration.
And this is during their run
that went up until January.
So that's what we've got so far.
And other interesting thing
-- way to look at this,
is to compare the black
holes that LIGO has seen.
So these are the two merging
into the one, from the one event.
This is the second event.
And this is the candidate event.
And then this is all the
black holes we've known
about to date through
x-ray astronomy.
And one thing you notice is that
these ones look kind of different.
In fact, they're much bigger.
And this is already
interesting to astronomers.
And this is exactly the reason why
we want to go do gravitational waves
as astronomers is because, aha,
I can look at a new population
of sources and I can learn
something new about the universe.
And this is why we want to do
gravitational wave astronomy.
Okay. So I'm to the last paper,
but I'm going to spend a little bit
of time on it because this is the
one paper that I'm an author on,
and this is the thing
that we're working on.
And we'd like to build a
gravitational wave detector
in space, and I'll explain why
in the next couple of slides.
But what this paper basically shows
is that largely due to the efforts
of the European Space Agency and the
European community, also some effort
from NASA, we're able to
basically fly a mission
which is flying right
now which we can sort
of demonstrate the technologies we'd
need to build a detector in space.
And I'll explain a little bit
about why we want to do that.
So people might have seen
the electromagnetic spectrum,
seeing a charge that looks kind of
like this where you have, you know,
frequency or wave length running
along the horizontal axis.
And you have things going from
radio waves up through, you know,
microwave and infrared and optical
and x-ray and, you know, gamma rays,
and all that kind of thing.
You have the same thing
in gravitational waves.
There's an entire spectrum.
There's not just one kind.
And we can have the spectrum
basically by their frequency
of the waves or by the
period of the waves,
how long it takes them
to go up and down.
And so what I plotted on the
bottom here are the different kinds
of detector -- well, actually
let me start with the top.
I put on the top here the
different kinds of sources
that we think produce waves
in those different bands.
So this purple band here sort
of lines up with this area.
That tells you that these kinds of
sources will produce frequent waves
with these kinds of frequencies.
These kinds of sources will
produce waves with these kinds
of frequencies, et
cetera, et cetera.
So on the bottom I had
different kinds of detectors.
So things like LIGO, which I'll
call terrestrial interferometers,
can see things from maybe down
to hertz up to like a kilohertz.
So they work in this band.
If you want to go lower,
you've got to go to space.
And it's kind of like the
same reason if you want
to do infrared astronomy.
You've got to get away from
the Earth's atmosphere.
In this case what we
have to get away
from is actually the
motion of the Earth itself.
The Earth is sort of
jiggling around so much
that we can't do low-frequency
gravitational wave detection
on Earth.
The other advantages --
remember that we have strain.
It's this change in
length over length.
If I go to space, four
kilometers is sort of expensive
for building vacuum tubes.
And, you know, eventually
you have to deal with things
like the curvature of the Earth if
you want to make it much longer.
In space, I can make it big.
In fact, I'd like to make this
like a million kilometers, right?
So let me talk a little
bit about the LISA Concept.
Now I've drawn it.
Here's this sort of -- this
cartoon is not my drawing,
but this sort of cartoon drawing
-- this thing has actually been --
the original sort of napkin sketch
like this was also in the '70s.
And people have been working
on this since the '80s.
It's just a little
bit farther behind.
And there was a NASA HISA
project where we fleshed this
out in quite great detail.
But the basic idea is we
want to build this triangle.
The triangle is kind of like
having two detectors with sort
of sharing one arm, so I think of
it as sort of two v-shaped detectors
that are kind of overlapped
or kind of half overlapped.
So that helps us get
that triangulation
and the rejecting of
instrument noise.
And make the arms big.
So maybe 5 million kilometers,
may 1 million kilometers,
something in that range.
So 5 million kilometers
is 14 times the distance
between the Earth and the moon.
So this is a big telescope.
The arms are actually basically
laser beams which we're using
to measure between the two
satellites, measure that distance.
And inside the satellite there's a
little cube that's actually freely
floating inside the satellite.
And that's the part we're
testing on Pathfinder.
That represents those little
points in general relativity.
So what can we do with LISA?
So there's a bunch of
different science areas.
I'm going to go over them
in pretty high detail.
But one is you could do the same
thing LIGO does where they look
at black hole mergers,
but you scale up the mass.
So instead of looking at 10 solar
mass black holes, you're looking
at million solar mass black
holes like the ones we have
at the centers of galaxies.
And these things are so loud,
there's such a large amount,
you can see them to the edge
of the observable universe.
So, basically, if there's any of
these things happenings anywhere
in the universe, we can see them.
And the estimates are
something like 10 per --
or a hundred per year for
an instrument like LISA.
And you'd learn about sort of both
how the black holes form and also
about how galaxies form
because we thing galaxies form
by basically merging together
and when they have black holes
in the center, those
black holes will merge.
And we can tract how
those black holes merge
and learn how the galaxies merge.
So that's what we'd
like to do with that.
There's also a really cool event,
so we know there's big massive black
holes at the centers of galaxies,
and occasionally little black
hole will fall into them.
Now oftentimes we see stars
falling into these things
and it produces an x-ray event
we call a tidal disruption.
And this is a very
interesting event.
But that's because the
star as it gets close
to the black hole's
gravity gets shredded apart,
and that's actually
interesting for an astronomer.
But it's sort of bad
if you're trying
to understand general
relativity because what you'd
like to do is drop a particle into
a black hole and watch how it orbits
and trace out the orbit and
see is it really the black hole
that Einstein had predicted.
And with a black hole,
if you drop --
use that as your test particle,
it can't get torn apart.
It's pure gravity, right?
And so this thing can orbit around
and they do these crazy orbits
and then eventually
plunge into the black hole.
And you can match those
orbits against the predictions
of general relativity and
probably make the most extreme test
of general relativity
that's conceivable.
So if you really want to understand
if gravity's going to break,
it's going to break here, right?
So this is where you want
to understand gravity.
You can also do some more sort of
traditional astronomy if you will
where we can get a census of
actually millions of these binaries
in the, what we call close binaries,
which are things we
know from x-ray studies.
Actually many of those black holes
that were in that chart before,
these kinds of stars that
are in our own Milky Way.
But they're all emitting
gravitational waves.
And this actually kind of makes this
cacophony of millions of sources
that are all on top of one another
and it's a big data
analysis challenge to try
to pick the individual ones out.
But we think we could pick
out maybe 10s of thousands
and actually do things like --
they'll tell you, well
how many black hole,
black hole binaries are
there in the Milky Way
versus neutron star
black hole binaries
versus white dwarf,
white dwarf binaries?
You know, these kind of things
that astronomers are interested in.
And we could maybe even do things
like try to map the milky way
in white dwarf binaries, you know?
How does that distribution in the
galaxies differ from the stars?
So this is really -- you know, and
another really interesting thing is
that there's 14 of these
objects that are know right now.
So that is they're physical
really known objects
which we could point to in a sky.
And you can calculate, you know,
how big is a gravitational
wave, and could LISA see them?
And, in fact, LISA could
see them quite easily.
So their source is like guaranteed.
You turn them on and they're
just there because they're
on all the time, these stars.
And then, of course, there's
the unexpected sources.
So maybe really exotic physics,
maybe some exotic astrophysics,
or who knows what?
So that's why we'd like to do this.
So why are we doing this
thing called LISA Pathfinder?
And I like to call it, for this
thing I call picophobia, right?
So this is basically the --
and I made up this definition.
You won't find this.
But this is the extreme
or irrational fear
of large negative exponents,
especially when related
to engineering requirements.
So in a place like LIGO, I mean,
yes, many engineers were involved,
but it was really driven
by experimental physicists.
When you go to do something in space
flight, you really don't want people
like me, you know, the
physicists, in there,
you know, building the spacecraft.
You want the engineers doing
it because they're going
to do it right, and it's not
going to blow up on the launch pad
or not going to break, you
know, halfway up there.
So you need to be able to
communicate these requirements.
And a lot of times, you
know, we go and we say, well,
we need to keep this thing
stable to a picometer.
And they go, what's a picometer?
So, really, there's some sort of
this thought that doing something
like LISA was just too hard.
So instead of doing
LISA we did this.
We cut out one arm.
We put it in a single spacecraft.
We shrunk it down so it
fit in a single spacecraft.
And we got this thing
called LISA Pathfinder.
So LISA Pathfinder is two test
masses with a laser interferometer
between them it's like
this big, right?
So two test masses,
laser interferometer.
So when you do this,
you actually get rid
of all your gravitational
wave signal
and you keep all of your noise.
So if you're an astronomer,
that's a bad deal, right?
We keep all the noise
and lose all the signal.
If you're an instrument scientist,
that's actually a pretty good deal
because you want to
understand the noise, right?
And so for the instrument scientist
this really lets us understand well,
how well can we put this
test mass in free fall?
How well can we measure the
distances between these things?
And is it good enough
so that if we scaled it
up to the full detector we could
make the gravitational reproduction.
So here's this idea
of drag-free control.
So when we get up in space,
we have this little cube.
Actually, I have some little
plastic models I can pull
out in the Question
and Answer period.
So you have this cube and we
let it go inside the spacecraft.
So it's actually in a little cavity
in the spacecraft, and
it's freely falling.
So it's not touching
the spacecraft at all.
So imagine that something comes
and pushes on the spacecraft
like let's say the
solar wind is a big one.
Well now the spacecraft is no longer
in free fall, and it will start
to move towards the test mass
and eventually crash into it.
But we have a sensor
system that senses that
and we have a thruster system
that can -- counteracts that.
And we fly in balance
around that test mass.
And so I like to think of it as a
flying shield that sort of flies
around the test mass
and shields it from kind
of any external disturbances.
So that's the idea
of drag-free control.
So what does things look like?
So here are their challenges.
So here's our test masses.
We need to isolate them from forces
and we express our requirement
in acceleration, so 1G, 10
meters per second squared,
is acceleration on Earth.
We want to do femto-G, 10
to the minus 15 of that.
We need to have thrusters that can
push this several-hundred-kilograms'
spacecraft around.
They thrust with precisions
at sort of sub-micro-Newton.
So their total thrust is
in a micro-Newton range.
That's about the weight
of a mosquito in 1G.
And their fluctuation is
10th of a micro-Newton
or hundredths of a micro-Newton.
That's the weight of the
mosquito's antennae, right?
So that's the kind of fluctuation.
An inkjet printer has a thrust
of about a hundred
micro-Newtons, right?
So these are tiny,
tiny little thrusters.
But they have to be very precise.
We have to do this precision
optometricalogy [assumed spelling],
so here we see during
one of the integration,
this is that interferometer
picture from back here.
That one. So that's what
it really looks like.
And then, of course,
the spacecraft itself --
this is really where
that picophobia comes in.
You have to keep track of it
thermally and magnetically
and all those kinds of things.
And one really interesting
thing is you have
to keep track of it gravitationally.
And that means we need to know
the mass of every single part
that we put around
because the own --
the gravity of the spacecraft
itself actually pulls those test
masses around.
And we have to keep those balanced,
otherwise they were going
to fall into the walls.
And, for instance, see
these little blue things?
These are little zip-ties, little
cable-ties, that are holding cables
that are going to the
photoreceivers.
Well, we care about the
mass of those things.
Not because they're going
to keep the spacecraft from,
you know, being able to launch.
We care about the mass because
they're going to pull the test mass
around from their own gravity.
So what they had to do was
they would weigh each zip-tie,
put it on there, zip it, clip
the end off, weight the clip,
write down the difference, and
say that's how much mass I left
in there, and then add that
to their gravity model.
And I mean, it's just incredible.
That's the kind of
engineering that we had to do.
So here's some pretty pictures
of -- here's integration.
So this shows you the
scale of this thing.
It's actually pretty small.
Here's the whole payload
going to the spacecraft.
So this is the whole
spacecraft here.
Here's one of the thrusters
which is provided by NASA.
And then here is the rocket
in French Guiana getting ready
to be launched last December.
And there is the launch
on December 3rd,
UTC December 2nd in East Coast time.
Well, I didn't get to go down
but I got to watch it online.
And, let's see.
What do we do in LISA Pathfinder?
So, basically, what we do is we've
been running European payloads
which actually several of us in the
U.S. are actual -- also working on.
I ran from March to June.
The NASA payload's
running right now.
And there's a mission
extension that just approved.
It will run through -- from
October 30 to next May.
And what we basically do is
we do two modes of operation.
In one mode of operation we sort
of sit there and measure the noise.
So we want to see how well did
we place these tests masses
in free fall, right?
And on another mode, we do
experiments where we try
to understand, well,
what's causing the noise?
So we maybe deliberately
make something worse.
So like we change the
temperature and we see,
does that make the test mass move?
And we sort of make these
deliberate couplings
to understand all the noise.
And eventually we want to build
this thing we call a noise budget
where you have all the
different contributions that --
and this is just, you
know, four of them.
But there's like 50 of them.
And we do experiments to understand
all these different things
so that we basically have a model
that we then checked against a --
against a flight [inaudible] --
against a real piece of hardware.
And now we have a lot of confidence
that if we go to build LISA --
and we say well what if we make
the temperature like this instead
of like that, or make
the magnetic field
like this instead of like that?
We understand that this -- we can
use that model that's been checked
against reality to build
the next instrument
and have a lot of confidence.
And this is just sort of cute.
This is the way it
really works, right?
So you have all this grand science
and you end up with one guy typing
on a laptop and 10
people standing around him
with coffee going, is
that the right thing?
You know, what's going on here?
Can you make this hurry?
And this, this is in the
Operations Room in Germany.
And this is where we spent
a lot of our time recently.
So what's the big result?
So this is the big result
that came out of that paper.
It's a little technical,
but since it is our result,
I wanted to try to go through it.
So, basically this is a plot
where on the vertical axis
here you have the acceleration,
and it's in these funny units
of meters per second
squared per root hertz,
so forget about the --
figure out the units.
But meters per second
squared is acceleration.
And it's basically saying how
much acceleration do you have
from ideal perfect free fall?
And these numbers are
in a logarithmic scale.
So this is 10 to the
minus 12, so a trillionth.
This is a 10th of a trillionth.
This is a hundredth of a trillionth.
And this is whatever the thousandth
of a trillionth is -- quadrillionth.
So that's the size of these numbers.
And then over here is
basically frequency.
So this is saying if I have
fluctuations in the acceleration,
how fast are those fluctuations?
So the main point of this is
that you want things to be low.
So the lower they are
on this, the better.
And the -- and going from here
to here is a factor
of 10 better, right?
And from here to here is
another factor of 10 better.
That's a logarithmic scale.
So this orange line here
is where we said we wanted
to go for LISA Pathfinder.
It was a tech demo.
We weren't going to try to get
to the full mission performance.
The green line here is where
we would need to go for LISA.
And this purpose line
here is where we got.
And this white line is basically
-- explain our noise problem.
This is a couple of months old.
We're actually, actually
a little bit better now,
actually below the LISA requirement.
So it was just incredible
because not only did we meet
our requirements and exceed it
by quite a bit, but we
basically are ready to do LISA
and that's the main
message out of that paper.
So if we look ahead, there's a lot
of really interesting
things going on.
So on LIGO there's some further
upgrades, so basically to get
to their final advanced LIGO
configuration they wanted to sort
of make some upgrades,
do some science,
make some upgrades, do some science.
And so since the end of January,
when they stopped their data-taking,
they've been doing major upgrades,
and actually are about to come
on again in a period
of weeks to months.
So something in like late September
or early October they'll turn
on again for another six-month run
with a little bit better
sensitivity.
And you would expect that they
should get at least another handful
of these black hole
events, maybe even more.
So that's really exciting.
Also really exciting on the ground
is this worldwide network that's
being developed.
So the Italians have a
three-kilometer detector.
It's a collaboration with
the French and the Germans
and some other groups as well.
And they're very close
to turning on.
They're hoping to be able to turn
on in this advanced configuration
and join LIGO during their
second observing run.
Having three detectors really helps
you do the localization and figure
out where on the sky the
signal's coming from.
Interestingly, there have been
efforts for a long time to try
to get a detector going in India.
They kind of stalled in
the Indian Parliament.
The day after the detection, the
Indian Prime Minister tweeted
that he's going to do LIGO in India.
It's called, you know --
and it happened, right?
So I mean, just to get the detection
and [singer-snap] bang,
they were on it.
And, you know, the Prime
Minister tweets it and all
of a sudden it gets
right through Parliament.
So, I mean, it was pretty
amazing to see that going.
The Japanese are building a
detector inside a mountain.
They're going to make it cryogenic.
You know, they're sort of trying to
push the next level of technology.
They're working very hard.
And then on the, on the -- in
space, for this laser ferrometer
or LISA concept, we
continue go get these results
from Pathfinder for the next year.
And we'll be analyzing them.
The European Space Agency and
NASA are working right now to sort
of figure out how to partner on a
LISA-scale mission with launch maybe
in the late 2020's,
maybe early 2030's.
And so this is really
starting to heat up, again,
largely due to the interest
generated from LIGO.
There was just a report that came
out from the National
Research Council last week
that said the U.S.
really ought to do this.
And so that's very encouraging.
And then two things I didn't
mention, if you noticed,
when I did the -- with
the spectrum plot.
There was two other
kinds of detectors
that were farther down there.
So frequencies below what
we could do with LISA.
There's a thing called
pulsar timing arrays.
And these are kind of cool.
They use those radio pulsars
as like a galactic scale
gravitational wave antenna.
And so they're coming
along quite nicely.
And then there's something called
cosmic microwave background
polarization which actually made a
bunch of news a couple of years ago
where they thought they detected
this polarization signal which comes
from gravitational waves
produced in the Big Bang.
It turns out that was
probably due to dust.
But the general principle
is still completely valid
and it's very likely that
eventually, you know,
whether it's a period of
years or maybe 10 years,
these signals will start
to get detected as well.
So it's a very bright future
for gravitational waves.
And so my last chart in summary
here is basically that, you know,
if we kind of look at gravitational
waves over the last hundred years,
they've moved from being a
mathematical curiosity to sort
of an astrophysical
reality where we knew
that they would be
in principal there.
We could sort of see
them indirectly.
And now they're a new
tool for doing astronomy
that we can measure
gravitational waves with LIGO,
we can understand new kinds of
black holes, we'll soon be able
to measure them with things
like LISA and pulsar timing,
and do totally new
kinds of astronomy.
So in the next hundred years,
we're going to extend our
gravitational wave years or eyes
from just this one little slice of
the frequency spectrum we can do
on the ground to an entire
array of gravitational waves.
And we'll have all kinds of new
insights for physics and astronomy.
And I think I'll end the talk
there and take questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus:
That was incredible.
And I'm glad you're young
because maybe you'll be able
to see some of these crazy --
>> Ira Thorpe: That's the hope.
>> Stephanie Marcus: --
advances in the future.
We could either have
questions and answers
or we could have a quiz [laughter].
I think we'll do the
questions and answers.
And if you would repeat
the question --
>> Ira Thorpe: Absolutely.
>> Stephanie Marcus: -- so everybody
and we can also get a
[inaudible] on our webcast.
>> Ira Thorpe: Am I picking the --
>> Stephanie Marcus:
You get to pick,
>> Ira Thorpe: Okay.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Yes.
>> Ira Thorpe: You, sir.
>> How do you determine
where the event occurred?
>> Ira Thorpe: Yes, it's basically
localizations from time of flight.
So with the LIGO detectors,
you have two very separate --
oh, the question is, how do
you determine the location?
I forgot to do that part.
So you have the two detectors.
And the wave basically
hits one detector first
and then hits the other detector.
And by knowing the time difference,
you can basically draw an arc
on the sky of where it
could have come from.
Now, an arc is not that
good for localization.
You can do a little bit better
because, with a little bit
of subtleties of sort of how loud
the event was and everything,
you can actually constrain that
arc into a little strip on the sky.
But what you can do with two
detectors is still quite difficult
for, say, someone trying to follow
up with it with a optical telescope.
It's just too big of an area of sky.
That's why the detector
in Italy and the detector
in India are really important,
because when you get that --
with those third detectors
and a fourth detectors you get
to draw different arcs
in different directions,
and then they only converge
in small parts in the sky,
and you get a little
patch on the sky.
For LISA, because our
sources are long-lived,
the satellites actually
move in their orbit.
They're in an orbit around
the sun and so they move
in their orbit pretty
significantly during the event.
So the event lasts for months
or years, as opposed to lasting
for a small fraction of a second.
And there we can use
the fact that both --
you get a modulation in the
amplitude and the strength
of the wave from the motion,
and you get a Doppler shift,
basically not modulation
of frequency,
but as the satellites are moving
around you can use that to localize.
And just behind you.
>> What can you say in great length
on the gravitational [inaudible]?
>> Ira Thorpe: If you
tell me the frequency,
I can tell you the wavelength.
And so, basically, it's the
same formula you use for light.
They propagate at the speed of
light, and so it's just a ratio
of the frequency and the
wavelength gets you the speed.
So for some -- and
that's one of the reasons.
So for a millihertz-size
gravitational wave, which is what we
like to go after for something like
LISA, the wavelengths are scales
of millions of kilometers which is
why we want to build our detector
to be a million kilometers.
So, in general -- there's a general
principle for building antennas.
You want to build your antenna to be
roughly the size of the wavelength
of the radiation you're
trying to measure.
And that's saying what you're
building, electromagnetic antennas
or if your building a
gravitational wave antenna.
>> So half-way.
>> Ira Thorpe: Half-way or
quarter-wave or what -- yeah, right.
I said roughly.
I'm being a physicist here, right.
Same order of magnitude.
There's on in the back.
There you go.
>> You said that the events
last [inaudible] months.
How are you going to distinguish
between two events colliding?
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah, right.
So, again, so this is a
problem for LISA, not for LIGO.
So for LIGO, everything
is smaller masses,
and so it happens more quickly.
And you have to remember,
when we say smaller masses,
we're still talking about, you know,
tens of times the mass of our sun,
and they were revolving
around each other faster
than your kitchen blender
goes around, right?
So that's like pow, right?
But for LISA, we're talking
about millions of solar mass,
and they're going around
each other every hour.
So it's much slower, right?
But still that whole
event lasts for sort
of months where we can detect it.
And, yeah, you're right.
We could have multiple events.
And so you basically do it the
same way your radio station --
radio receiver in your car can
pick out different stations.
You have to know something
about the --
about what the signal is
that's being produced, right?
So when I turn on the radio I know
that, okay, the radio station I want
to listen to is at this
particular frequency
and it has this particular
encoding of the information.
That's what the numerical
relativity gets you.
It says, I have this template
for a wave form and basically
if I have multiple signals
I need multiple templates,
and I try to do a fit of all
the templates at the same time
to try to pull out the signals.
So that's a data analysis
challenge for sure.
But it's definitely a
-- it's a tractable one.
And it's actually something that
we've done a lot of work on.
And we have these things
called mock data challenges,
where basically we get together,
we agree on the types of signals
that could be in a data
stream, and we have one group
of people produce a data
stream with some signals in it,
and the other people try
to go find those signals.
And we see, can they
find all of them?
Did they find the right
ones, you know?
And you don't tell them how
many are in there, right?
And they have, you know, a
few months to go find them,
and then they use their
algorithms on them, they find them,
and then that seems
to generally work.
So that's how we do it.
A question back here.
>> You talked about
polarized gravity waves.
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah.
>> Are you just talking
about linearly polarized
or circularly polarized.
We've got a right-handed
or left-handed --
>> Ira Thorpe: Right.
So, well, okay, so the question's
about polarization and
gravitational waves.
So the polarization's
a little bit different
than the polarization
that you get for light.
And that's -- it's the same
math, but it basically has to do
with the fact that there's only
a single charge for gravitation.
So there's only a positive mass.
There's not positive
mass and negative mass.
And so as a result, we have these
quadrupolar fields as opposed
to dipole fields, and the
polarizations are in a different --
so there are polarization states.
Mathematically there's six of them.
And only two of them are predicted
to exist from general relativity.
And those are the two that I showed.
So there's the plus polarization,
which is basically doing the
stretching along this direction,
like this.
And then there's a
cross, which is what a 45.
Trying to do my gravitational
wave dance.
So those are the two polarizations.
>> It sounds like electromagnetic.
>> Ira Thorpe: It's very
similar, but rather than the --
for instance, the polarizations
aren't rotated by 90 degrees.
They're rotated by 45 degrees.
And it's because of the
symmetry of the field.
So, yeah, the math is
the same, but it's --
the intuition's a little
bit different.
A question in the back.
>> In your next 100
years in space --
>> Ira Thorpe: Not my next
hundred years [inaudible].
I'm not that young.
>> Yes, I am, yeah.
What are the [inaudible]
discoveries that you can find
through gravitational
waves, et cetera?
>> Ira Thorpe: Well, right.
So there's the Yogi Berra quote
about hard to predict things,
especially the future, or whatever.
But, you know, I think,
first of all,
you can look to what LIGO's done
now and see already we saw a class
of black holes that we
didn't really expect.
These things of the 30
solar mass, 60 solar mass.
We didn't really think, you know,
that it really makes it difficult
for the astronomers who have
tried to figure out, you know,
where those things came from.
So that's one example.
You could have other kinds of
astrophysical, you know, surprises.
All right.
So maybe there are a thousand
solar mass black holes.
We don't know, right?
So we think now that there's
basically two different kinds.
There's sort of a tens
of solar mass black holes
that come from dying stars.
And there's a million solar
mass black holes that come
from we don't know where.
But we know that they're
there, right?
There's all this thought
that there's been a mass
gap, but maybe there's not.
And the gravitational waves would
be a good way to look at it.
So that's an example sort
of exotic astrophysics.
There could also be exotic physics.
So if you come up with these exotic
theories like cosmic strings,
you know, almost all of them
couple to gravity in some way.
And so there's ideas of like
if you have cosmic strings
that have little kinks in
them and those kinks relax,
they'll produce a little
burst of gravitational waves.
We could go look for those.
I would try to, you know, build
a whole detector to do that.
Well, I would.
But I wouldn't be able
to get the money to do it
because it's kind of speculative.
But, you know, it's hard to
predict what you're going to see.
So I think broadly speaking
it's, you know, you know,
astrophysics surprises
and physics surprises.
And we've got a good chance of
getting after both of those.
There one's in here.
>> If you happen to be looking at
one of these colliding black holes
that you're seeing gravitationally
with an optical telescope
or a radio telescope, would
you have seen anything?
>> Ira Thorpe: Okay.
Excellent, excellent,
excellent question.
So the question is,
could you see anything
with electromagnetic telescope?
So, the answer is, in
principle, in principle, yes.
Okay? So it really has
to do with the sources.
And it's actually something that
we'd really like to go after.
We call it multi-messenger
astronomy.
So there's this big idea of
multi-wavelength astronomy
where I look at the same kind of
object with radio waves and optical
and UV and all kinds of
things, and I put the sort
of full-color picture together
to understand the object.
Here is the idea is if we could
look at gravitational waves
and electromagnetic
waves at the same time,
I've got completely different and
kind of complimentary channels
of information that I can
use to understand a system.
Now for the system that LIGO
saw, it's two black holes.
And black holes are pure gravity
and they basically don't emit
electromagnetic radiation, right?
So you wouldn't expect that any
kind of telescope could see one.
Now that said, black holes in nature
are often surrounded by some kind
of gas of something, and they might
make some sort of something, right,
some little burst, right?
And there actually are people
that were working to try
to follow up these events.
And there was a sort of tentative
maybe correlation with a,
with some gamma rays that were
detected by the Fermi mission.
I think it's probably unlikely
that that was actually correlated,
but it was a very, very, very
interesting, interesting paper.
Now, when LIGO starts detecting
things like neutron stars --
so there's a little
bit less massive.
They're going to need a
little bit more sensitivity
to have a good chance of
detecting those things.
But that's one of the things
they're really going after.
Neutron stars are made
out of matter.
They're very similar to black holes
but they're made out of matter.
And when they crash
into one another --
we have a very high confidence that
they produce, if they're pointed
at us, they produce gamma ray
bursts which we can see to the --
way father than we could detect
the gravitational waves from LIGO.
Or, if we're seeing them
from some other angle,
they might produce a
sort of small super nova.
I think about a kilanova.
And people are trying
to go after that, too.
So once LIGO starts
seeing gravitational waves
from neutron stars, there will
be a lot of opportunity for that.
And with LISA, there's
also lots of opportunities.
But that's the long answer, okay?
That's exactly what we'd like to do,
is we'd like to do
multi-messenger astronomy.
Maybe there's one here in the front.
>> Yeah. This is kind
of a practical question.
As a physicist, I definitely think
we should be supporting this kind
of research.
And I know that some of
the news releases said
that the European Space Agency
launched the LISA Pathfinder.
What percent or amount is the U.S.
contributing to this research --
>> Ira Thorpe: Whew.
Hit the political question.
>> -- compared to other countries?
Do you have any idea --
>> Ira Thorpe: Anybody from NASA
Headquarters here [laughter]?
Well, okay.
So the LISA project -- so
there's interest both in the U.S.
and in Europe to doing this thing.
And back in 2000, the two agencies
got together and started a project.
And they started a project
to build the full thing.
And now as part of
that, they said we want
to go do a technology demonstrator.
And both the technology demonstrator
and the full mission were
roughly 50-50 partnerships.
Now the technology demonstrator sort
of started to drag on a little bit.
There were some funding
problems on the NASA side,
some technical problems
on both sides.
And basically, the Europeans
doubled-down on their funding
and spent like 10 times more
money than they were expecting to.
And NASA kind of cut if off and
said we're only going to do so much.
So for Pathfinder, it's almost
like an 80-20 kind of expenditure
in terms of 20% NASA
and 80% European.
Now then, at the same time,
we were still holding
together this idea we're going
to do an equal partnership with
the Europeans on LISA and --
but back in 2011, NASA
had to kind of --
we basically had to pull out
because we didn't have the budget.
And so then the Europeans
said well, we're going to try
to make the detector a
little less capable and see
if we can do it on our own.
They've been pushing that idea
for the last several years.
And now they're starting to make
it look a little bit more real.
They've gotten a selection, but
with a nominal launch date in 2034,
which is kind of long
for a lot of us.
And now with all the interesting
gravitational waves there's renewed
interest in the U.S. The
Europeans certainly could use some
financial help.
I think we could also
provide some technical help.
And we're trying to work with
Europeans to figure out what kind
of share the U.S. can play.
And actually this report I just
mentioned in the National Academy
that just came out like last week,
was a review of the decadal survey.
So the decadal surveys are things
that set policies for space science.
And one of their main
recommendations was the U.S. should
get back into LISA at the majority
-- you know, at that sort of,
you know, a significant role.
So that's all playing
out now in the politics.
But I think it's pretty likely
that we'll have a significant role.
>> But one follow-up.
I asked that question
because it almost looks to me
like we're repeating the
history of what happened to CERN.
I moved up there from [inaudible].
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah.
>> And we had a big
project down there --
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah.
>> -- that got cancelled.
And now we have nothing in
the area of super colliders.
And there is one --
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah, people
are aware of that, for sure.
I think that analogy's not lost
on people and I think, you know,
both the headquarters folks and
the scientists are working hard
to make sure that doesn't happen.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Write to your Congressman.
And there will be a collection
at the door for NASA [laughter].
They probably want us out of here
but do you want to do one more?
>> Ira Thorpe: I'm happy.
I'll stay until they kick me out.
>> Stephanie Marcus: People
can come up here afterwards.
>> It's a good thing because I
have thousands of questions --
>> Ira Thorpe: Thousands?
Okay [laughter].
>> Believe me.
>> Ira Thorpe: Okay.
>> [Inaudible] question.
>> Ira Thorpe: How about just one?
>> A very special question.
Nineteen-nineteen,
Eddington does the experiment.
Finds it. I'm trying to understand,
why did the general public react
to this information in
the way that the result is
that Albert becomes this iconic
figure of the 20th century?
>> Ira Thorpe: So the question
is, why did the public react
to the prediction of --
the verification of
Einstein's prediction?
I mean, I think because it was just
-- it was such a wacky prediction.
And to have it actually come
true was just sort of amazing.
I mean, people have this -- I think
largely due to this Einstein --
they have this idea that
that's how science works.
That sort of people
sit and they say, well,
I'm going to make a
theory and I'm going
to predict what's going to happen.
And then somebody goes
out and measures it.
That almost never happens.
It usually is the complete
opposite way.
We go and measure something.
We go, what the heck was that?
And then the theorists have to
figure out, you know, what it meant.
And it's only those rare cases
where people make a prediction
that's very outlandish
and then it takes a long time and a
significant effort to go verify it,
that people really become,
you know, lauded and famous.
And Einstein's the
key example of that.
>> Okay.
>> Ira Thorpe: And --
>> [Inaudible] here is that
we're discussing special
and general relativity.
I would have figured the
population in 1919 was maybe
at best 10,000 people on the
Earth understood what those papers
were about.
>> Ira Thorpe: I think that's
probably on the Earth now.
It's still smaller
than that [laughter].
>> That's right.
So why would the general
public react
so something they had absolutely no
idea what they were talking about?
>> Ira Thorpe: I guess
you would have
to ask the sociologists and -- yeah.
>> That's what I keep doing.
>> Ira Thorpe: Okay.
>> That's why I'm here.
>> Ira Thorpe: Well,
I'm a physicist.
So I --
>> Still but you're here.
I get to talk to you.
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah.
>> Second question.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Ooh, ooh.
>> Do you accept the existence of --
>> Ira Thorpe: I was just
going to say -- okay?
>> Do you accept the
existence of entanglement?
>> Ira Thorpe: Quantum entanglement.
Yes. But it has nothing
to do with this.
>> Well, I understand.
>> Ira Thorpe: Yeah, okay.
>> But I'm just saying, you
know, because [inaudible].
>> Stephanie Marcus: Thank you all.
>> Ira Thorpe: All right.
Thanks.
>> All right.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ira Thorpe: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.